concours maman les chéris big flo et oli
sont avec nous alors big flo et oli je
vous le dis en écriture en musique ce
sont vraiment des génies voir un joli et
il adore en plus sa télé c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont avec nous et vous leur avait
proposé des mots ici les chroniqueurs
juste avant il y avait le mot vue
football une tartiflette casquette
biscotte maman fatou métabolisme
freudien coupe et dont tartiflette et
casquettes c'était donc les
téléspectateurs sur twitter qu'ils ont
proposés vous allez nous faire donc
c'est cette semaine au freestyle
ouais c'est comme un freedom et au
niveau musical
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je veux la vente du temps qui essaie
d'être cool c'est ça me fait pas plus
sinon le vieux qui essaient de checker
mais qui sait un comme ça sans ça sens
où les jeunes alors les chéris alors
vous allez dites moi on dirait sans
déconner on dirait qu'ils vont donner
les résultats des primaires
écoutez ici à solférino pour l'instant
marc simon brieuc et on t'attend voilà
alors qu'est ce qui se passe on y va à
quoi sert votre avis la terrasse vous
pouvez du rouleau mais en fait on a
écrit dessus tout simplement mais ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est moi parce que je
croyais que vous retenez tout dans la
tête
oui je me suis dit ça va c'est que c'est
ton émission le les concepts et où tu
dois les connaître tout ça c'est écoutez
je ne sais pas du tout ce que vous êtes
très beau très beau ordinateur attention
c'est parti
vous avez passé tous les mois ok cristal
en direct de touche pas à mon poste
on y va acter précis hier cyril devrais
je suis présent 1
on m'a demandé d'écrire un texte en cinq
minutes chrono
alors je me suis boulet besoin
d'instruments et fêter la sono ampli
talent à la télé je vous présente le hip
hop le frère était mon mec totti
personnes wifi lit de biscottes
au milieu de tous ces vieux je suis
seule avec mes baskets delormeau a
tellement la grosse tête qui peut plus
mettre de casquette je prends les mecs
j'ai l'impression de passer un oral et
tous mes potes en bas rêve de finir en
couple avec enora hier jean michel maire
est encore parti faire la fête
j'ai un recul de montagnards qui veulent
la tartiflette si je foutais la merde et
j'écrivais même à l'école ils touchent
des boues jean michel maire mais lui n'a
jamais fait de football n'ont pas de
temps alors fitch fait bouger le stylo
elle veut je place le mot freudien à
l'épreuve de philo j'ai tellement de
flou quand je prends le mac menemy
agonise au final je crois que la musique
et danse mon métabolisme j'ai une tête
bizarre way le rap c'est mon seul atout
j'ai fait le tour du monde à la
recherche de mafate ou depuis la télé
j'avais promis que j'en ferais rien ma
tête j'entends des voix comme jeanne
d'arc ou marc antoine le vrai j'ai
l'impression d'être en course club la
même pour parler et si vous faites deux
millions ce soir c'est grâce à ma mère
l'a prévenu tout le quartier
le mec a dit mot
question qu'il a 12 pistes mais je garde
mon calme convives jean luc lemoine
goodies et tbilissi les textes nuls
au moins il aura été main juste avant la
fin j'en profite
coucou maman
[Applaudissements]
barbara bach baba bataille
j'adorais breton est bien visible depuis
la terre
micheline excellent inverse
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien tout ça
[Musique]